Endlessly debating with her romantic and intellectual partner, Jean-Paul Sartre,...
...de Beauvoir explored free will, desire, rights and responsibilities,...
...and the value of personal experience.
In the years following World War II, these ideas would converge into the school of thought...
...most closely associated with their work: existentialism.
Where Judeo-Christian traditions taught that humans are born with preordained purpose,...
...de Beauvoir and Sartre proposed a revolutionary alternative.
They argued that humans are born free and thrown into existence without a divine plan.
As de Beauvoir acknowledged, this freedom is both a blessing and a burden.
In the "Ethics of Ambiguity", she argued that our greatest ethical imperative...
...is to create our own life's meaning,...
...while protecting the freedom of others to do the same.